and you can call and leave him a message.
And when you call and leave him a message,
you just, on the outgoing message,
it's just whale sounds and then a beep,
which actually sounds a lot like a whale sound.
And they get a picture of their whale too.
So this is Randolph,
and Randolph belongs to a kid named Nico
who was one of the first kids to ever call in,
and I'll play you some of Nico's message.
This is the first message I ever got from Nico.
(Audio) Nico: Hello, this is Nico.
I am your owner, Randolph. Hello.
So this is the first time I can ever talk to you,
and I might talk to you soon another day. Bye.
Mac Barnett: So Nico called back, like, an hour later.
(Laughter)
And here's another one of Nico's messages.
(Audio) Nico: Hello, Randolph, this is Nico.
I haven't talked to you for a long time,
but I talked to you on Saturday or Sunday,
yeah, Saturday or Sunday,
so now I'm calling you again
to say hello and I wonder what you're doing right now,
and I'm going to probably call you again
tomorrow or today,
so I'll talk to you later. Bye.
MB: So he did, he called back that day again.
He's left over 25 messages for Randolph
over four years.
You find out all about him
and the grandma that he loves
and the grandma that he likes a little bit less —
(Laughter) —
and the crossword puzzles that he does,
and this is — I'll play you one more message from Nico.
This is the Christmas message from Nico.
[Beep] (Audio) Nico: Hello, Randolph,
sorry I haven't talked to you in a long time.
It's just that I've been so busy
because school started,
as you might not know, probably,
since you're a whale, you don't know,
and I'm calling you to just say,
to wish you a merry Christmas.
So have a nice Christmas,
and bye-bye, Randolph. Goodbye.
MB: I actually got Nico,
I hadn't heard from in 18 months,
and he just left a message two days ago.
His voice is completely different,
but he put his babysitter on the phone,
and she was very nice to Randolph as well.
But Nico's the best reader I could hope for.
I would want anyone I was writing for
to be in that place emotionally
with the things that I create.
I feel lucky. Kids like Nico are the best readers,
and they deserve the best stories we can give them.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)